my big struggle with you is uh
you could say it i've struggled with
pornography mostly
just i don't struggle with that oh you
don't no no no i i probably did when i
was younger i think everybody does
it's a racket but i'll tell you why
that's bad too oh it's bad it's horrible
i'll tell you why that's that's real bad
that is another oversaturated well
targeted
um
and it's it's
i always i always say this you remember
the first time you saw it oh yeah yeah
drawing just dude nick in our town two
dollars he would draw you some cuda for
the weekend right
so you'd hit him up on friday or
thursday night if you wanted a good
sketch right
but even on friday afternoon you could
get a a scribble i remember this and he
would freaking los you know he'd launch
you out that two dollar hit brian you'd
keep it all weekend
and then somebody chiseled a set of tits
into like a birch tree
and people would go out there and jerk
off by it
kids and adults bro not at the same time
but
you know you had to be respectful but
you know everybody was out there i
remember that it was a good time for me
it was it was
phil's dad's tape oh phil come on and we
were let's call phil
phil
and gil dad get his [ __ ] 80 year old
dad on the line
and talk about the lives he's ruined
phil's dad's tapes rui he
i was i don't care what anyone says when
you first see you're traumatized it's
crazy you look at the whole world
differently you look at women
differently
you you go from staring at them to
staring at them yeah and you think
that's why
and if you notice it's got more violent
more evil as time went like this whole
thing oh yeah who came up with if it
can't even do that smack smack smack
who said i love you so much smack smack
i love you so
god i love you yeah that is legal rape a
lot of heimlich maneuvers all there's
all types of like you know let me wait i
gotta punch in your temple right before
you orgasm let me know when you let me
pink you said you were orgasm you said
you were going there
come on we had to do this
again are you sure this time good yeah
okay crazy it's legal
rape and i yeah it's crazy that that and
like that it's just it's freaking
bizarre man it's the dark arts dude i
was addicted to it for a while and i do
pretty good these days you know but
every now and then it seeps in man you
know it's hard to keep it out
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one